It's interesting to look at these
things from obviously from multiple
perspectives,
which is another thing you
had your logs don't do.
Right.
Because for them everything
is one cause there's one,
that's how you can tell when you're
dealing with someone who's ideologically
possessed is they make everything
attributable to a single cause like power.
So,
but so one of the things that's happened
with the nuclear family that's quite
interesting too is that
parents are older and they,
and they have fewer children.
So you could imagine that that hot
house environment in some senses being
exaggerated for a bunch of reasons.
One is,
well your child is a lot more valuable
to you if you're older and you only have
one or two,
right?
Because you're not going
to get another chance.
That's first of all,
you might've had some trouble
having the child to begin with.
Um,
and you're not going
to get another chance.
So you've got all your
eggs are in one basket,
so to speak.
And then of course children don't have
the number of siblings they used to have.
And one of the things that's really
useful about having siblings is that they
keep you in your place,
right?
They,
they're primary socialization agents.
And I mean that can be brutal.
And that's reflected say in
the story of Cain and Abel.
You know,
that that internal household
dynamic with siblings can be,
can really become murderous and
that has to be kept under control.
But I think the,
the,
the hothouse flower person who's,
who's incapable of tolerating
any jibes or any or any testing,
any dominance hierarchy testing of
the sort that you said that men do,
part of that's the consequence of being
raised by older parents who have excess
resources,
who have no siblings because the child
is then of course special and that
specialness,
well there,
there seems to be an inverse relationship
between that specialness that's
protected and the person's
robustness and resilience.
And so,
and then that's cotton to,
or not cotton too.
That's,
that's uh,
uh,
pandered to by the universities,
which insist upon setting up a situation
where no one has ever offended by
anything,
any of the time.
That's something I also
can't understand at all.
Right.
Cause it,
let me just say that's a
huge point you just made.
Okay.
Because it's the upper middle class of
the purpose of the Fred professional
class who postpones having the children.
Okay.
Because they go to law school,
they go to medical school.
Right.
And they,
and they have the children after their,
their,
their settled.
Okay.
In,
in,
in a drop.
Okay.
So they're the ones.
W we have it injected this,
this,
this hypersensitive bourgeois.
I didn't,
you know,
code into the universities.
Now My,
my parents were 20 when they
married in 21 when they had me.
Okay.
It made,
my father was,
um,
you know,
uh,
went to college on the Gi Bill,
getting out of,
out of World War II.
So w w when I was born,
my father was still in college and
with the sweeping the floors and so on,
I am the product of young parents and
nature once actually Yucca parents.
Right.
Because,
because pregnancy is,
is,
is quicker,
it's safer.
Okay.
And so on.
And my parents had the energy.
Okay.
Too.
That's useful energy that can do spirit
that came out of world war two and so
on.
I'm positive that then.
Then my only other sibling
was born 14 years later.
Okay.
My father,
this point was a college professor.
Right.
All right.
So she had completely different
parents then and then I did.
So she has very excellent
manners and so on.
She's completely different.
Okay.
All right.
And I have all this energy of,
I mean it might,
my parents were just a lot of other teams,
but now today we have this situation.
No,
it's considered heresy
to raise this issue.
Okay.
That you have have young women are told,
okay,
there's one future for you.
You are a future leader.
Okay.
You must,
you must move forward
four years of college and,
and,
and perhaps it was a professional class.
All right,
so it may be the women,
young women's bodies are signaling
that they want to be [inaudible].
Maybe,
maybe there are signals
coming from the body,
right?
Maybe now wanting this,
this,
this system of education
that was devised for men.
Okay.
This is being funneled along
channel long and it's next.
Awesome.
All right.
So young women,
you know,
a few unhappy,
they don't know why they feel,
they have no sense of identity.
If they,
if they,
if they want to marry and
drop out of college and have,
have a baby,
they will be treated as
traitors to their class.
What you are future leader?
What have a baby only working class
women would do that I find working class
women.
Okay.
In general.
Far more rounded as personalities.
They express themselves forcefully.
They have body language
that takes up space.
Okay.
A man says something to
them on the street there,
right back in their face and so on.
It does the bourgeois girls.
Okay.
Who are talking to them at their core.
They are a special,
okay,
we'll have to postpone actual life.
Okay.
For him for all these years,
these cds,
these other girls who are,
who are,
who misjudged the
fraternity parties setting.
These are the girls who like rotten for
parental protection and handholding on,
on the,
on the committee investigating what
went wrong on our date and so on and so
forth.
So yes,
I think that you have located,
that's very interesting.
The idea that the,
that these,
these young girls,
okay.
Who are so sensitive.
Okay.
In College,
so I'm able to handle their sex life
are the product of older parents because
they went through the
professional career track.